by Alex Jones this is just kind of after
the show I want because I know this was
a topic that is going to take a little
bit longer to unpack you were just
talking about sort of demonic
apparitions and what they do in Silicon
Valley now here's one thing I will say I
have not had any experience with DMT or
like hallucinogenic drugs but I do know
that Joe Rogan and he brought him have
talked about this and it's fascinating
to me that they've talked about having
shared hallucinations which you don't
really get when it's a hallucination
right if it's in your mind if it's just
something that your own you know deep
there and your subconscious you're cheb
elements conjuring up you wouldn't all
see the same thing and this is something
that other people have talked about in
taking these drugs here's kind of and
this is what I thought was very
interesting I think there were some some
missed connections sometimes with you
and Eddie and Joe a little bit what
specifically once the pot came out but I
didn't was interesting that you were
bringing up was talking about kind of
this historical opening of a door and as
a Christian I do believe this certainly
if you're taking all kinds of
hallucinogenic drugs you're opening a
door in distancing yourself from God
where you might be more prone to let's
call it demonic or evil influence is
that relatively accurate kind of
interpretation that is exactly what I
was trying to say I don't take DMT I'm
not taking that I've never taken
ayahuasca and I've talked to hundreds of
people it's the total rage for like 15
years where I live in Austin and while
these are doctors they're scientists
they go yeah we were down in Peru or we
were down in Costa Rica or we were down
in beliefs and it was 20 of us it was 50
of us there was 100 of us and we saw the
spaceship land and the aliens walk out
and we all saw the same aliens and they
all thought I don't listen but the
doctor goes it's medical doctor I know
he appeals but I think that's just the
chemical I'm like no dude you don't all
see the same thing it lowers the Veil
the Bible talks about where you can see
your eyes see a lot more than just
visible light they're part of your brain
and so God has given us blinders so we
can operate the third dimension and not
go crazy seeing all the other stuff
going on around us in other dimensions
and so that's really what this comes
down to and San Francisco and the micro
dosing LSD
elites and an and all of them you see
these CEOs on TV and they're in under
hot lights and you can't even see their
eyes it's nothing but pupils right they
are obsessed with this and when I was a
kid growing up my parents had some
friends were research scientists out in
San Francisco they came to visit once so
I'm like seven eight years old at the
dinner table hearing about government
research projects where instead of
trying to go into space they're like
trying to contact and how they were
having government people take huge
amounts of drugs to contact the
clockwork help so I heard about that and
I and I talked about it over a decade
ago people researched it and found
Terence Mckenna and Timothy Leary
talking about it and basically look like
grey aliens said we're little elf hats
little green outfits and that's who you
talked to at least level one taking the
drugs and everything again I know dozens
and dozens and dozens of people that go
to ayahuasca and DMT cults because
they're all seeing and interacting with
the same thing it might be a 200 foot
tall prank Maness it might be a giant
demon it might be a bunch of little gray
aliens either our brains are all psychic
and are seeking up with somebody in one
liter and in the groups causing a
hallucination
maybe that's happening or we're breaking
through and something real is happening
biblically you read about it the Bible
says do not go to the sorcerers and take
pharmakeia you know the symbol of the
grinder and the bowl means drugs right
because the because that's what the
magician's in every culture would would
grind up hallucinogens take them and
they go the gods say build a pyramid or
build an altar and throw babies into it
whether it was the Babylonians or
whether it was the you know earlier
Egyptians or whether it was the Druids
or whether it was the Aztecs the bakken
aliens the parties that they would have
that's where debauchery comes from a lot
of people don't realize this the term
debauchery comes from the Bakken aliens
the parties that they would have word
they would they were drug-induced where
people who'd come out of a pile a human
orgy pile missing a limb the idea that
that sort of low and enjoy we're just
talking about this is what I did think
this was an interesting topic and I did
think that maybe Joe and Eddie can't
necessarily explore it as deeply since
they do partake a little bit more that's
not a condemnation on their choices I
just think they may be
somewhat uncomfortable with this idea
when you do lower let's be clear let's
be clear you read about Nero yes and n
people he would dress up like a werewolf
this is in the Roman histories and had a
kid tied up to a pole and run in with a
with a wolf skin on his back and kill a
kid exactly these elites take drugs like
like voodoo to try to interface with
something evil so in Eddie Bravo a Joe
Rogan they're nice guys so they go it's
a little alien saying I'm your friend
I'm your spirit guide come visit me more
but people they get deeper into it the
spirit guide was like the Bible says
lead you somewhere very bad and again
why do we think aliens are gonna come
from space they're gonna come from
another dimension again I agree they're
not aliens
they've always been with us and it's
demonic and listen you can search engine
this we have human-animal hybrids now we
have we have babies that have been
genetically edited we have world
government I mean it's all here and I'm
not saying I even have the answers all
I'm saying as the establishment is
obsessed with communicating via
pharmakeia drugs with other entities
just like in every history book and
every culture they always work right and
I do think that's important for people
to note that um listen I know they'll
say well Christians believe that God
told them this okay absolutely but the
difference is if you look at a lot of
pagan cultures and like some of the
cultures that you just mentioned they
all said well God told me this and
usually there's some kind of a drug or
chemically induced
influence when you look at the great
acts of evil and barbarism even some
lower level exactly it's a lower
dimension you access the devil through
drugs and jackin with what God or the
game is but but they know through higher
levels of chemicals released in the
brain you know during prayer during
emotional moments you're higher with God
that's when you get love and grace and
the universe it's all good but you get
into the occult all of its bad none of
it's good right
and I know Joe and Eddie have talked
about lowering your inhibitions quite a
bit you know even if it's just marijuana
as a good thing and in a certain there's
a component to that that I that I
probably agree with sometimes people
might be a little bit of titleist and
it's why you know the Bible says that
wine makes for was it a warm heart good
shivering good I don't know good cheer
cheery spirit I don't know I'm very
tired Jesus turned the water into wine
did turn into grape juice yes exactly
that's very important to note especially
when I understand modern fermentation
techniques that they wouldn't
had back then the wine would have keep
from keep it would have kept fermenting
until someone was drinking it but
they're specifically averse about you
know wine makes a fridge I don't know
the exact verse will have to get Gerald
back in here about it bringing a good
cheer of a warm heart warm spirit but it
does praise wine and again it wouldn't
really praise wine in that sense if it
were grape juice there is a value to a
well I think it's all in moderation the
finest wine doesn't make you see demons
no exactly there's my point is there's
value in a mild social lubricant that's
very different from changing the way
your brain functions to the point where
you're not able to make the same kinds
of decisions even though wiser exactly
it's like Avatar the movie Avatar
they believe they're taking drugs
whether it's voodoo or black magic or
any of this so that something else can
come in and run you right and that's
what this is is you're giving yourself
over there's something else that you're
being influenced by a interdimensional
offworld spiritual whatever you want to
call it thing that wants to kill steal
and destroy I mean you read the Bible
and you see what people the experiences
they have on ayahuasca and DMT it is
satanic and so that's why I like Joey's
a nice guy's like hey you should take
DMT and I'm like no fricking way man
it's not even a fear-based thing it's
the losing control and then be and then
like I'm in a damn room with a 200 foot
praying mantis I was talking to one of
the crew members and he took it about a
year ago and he was in this room with a
200 foot praying mantis for like ten
years it felt like telling him submit to
me
that sounds like a mist ya know it
doesn't sound very fun to me I didn't
notice you talking with with Eddie Bravo
and he seemed he cuz he used to be more
of a UFO guy and he did say no I don't
think they're coming I think they're
traveling through dimensions and maybe
they're think at one point said maybe
they're coming from below he seemed as
though he was more open to your point of
view and understand by the way I'm not
taking any particular sides here or
saying I agree with you on a percent Joe
or Eddie but is there kind of have there
been some off-air conversation with
Eddie where you're maybe witnessing a
little bit I mean I think Eddie overall
is a Christian and I and I think Joe's
coming along and I have had a lot of
offer conversation of those guys but I
mean I think Joe's really a genuine guy
who wants to get
along with everybody and that's how I
got sucked in and was being nice to the
corporate establishment and then he saw
the giant backlash to it and that kind
of got him back so you did a good job
yeah you know I guess on Thursday or is
it Wednesday whatever it was Tuesday
days don't fly by me this was Tuesday of
this week confronting them so I'm just
glad I don't think those guys are bad
guys I think they're good guys but yeah
I've been having arguments with Eddie
about all this because like jet
airplanes are real science is real they
say that I said the moon landing never
happened I never said that
we were just willing to have astronauts
died back then we're not willing to have
astronauts die today and there was a
secret military operation were a lot of
mid died people like Neil Armstrong who
was a test pilot the x-15 other things
there were other guys that died in
secret missions to pave the way for the
public missions and so they go Jones
says the moon landings faked and then
they never show it I said or you know
all these things I didn't say but notice
that you didn't we've landed on the moon
oh yeah well Stephen 90% of what they
say I said is like I'll say Hillary
Clinton is personally responsible for
murdering children in Syria by funding
the Arab Spring where men take children
and murder them and torture them or sell
their body parts and I'm reading news
articles right and then megyn kelly
edited on Fox News and said that I said
in a pizza place
they were murdering kids in a basement
right I mean it's just next-level how
they'll I want to clarify for our
listeners you do believe that we landed
on the moon
I just want to make sure that everyone
is clear and that was this because I do
and like you talked about with your
father working at UT I believe your dad
was a scientist correct yes my
grandfather was a colonel in the Air
Force actually would have made general
if he had a college degree he trained
all the fighter pilots basically who
worked for the Air Force would have had
to have been trained by my grandfather
he was out of Michigan and you know my
dad used have astronauts over for dinner
right they said they would run in the
same circles people of at a very you
know in a certain military rank it's
very common and of course a lot of those
fighter pilots would go on to to work
for NASA
so sometimes personal experience does
inform a worldview it's hard to
communicate that though sometimes
because other people haven't had that
same experience and this is one thing I
wanted one thing I wanted to ask you
talked about under Rogan show quite a
bit this is sort of a personal
conversation here I'm glad that we're
we're doing this as an extended version
you talked about sort of the psychosis
that comes in with seeing a lot of these
conspiracies seeing them play out and
then maybe at one point you were looking
for conspiracies in too many places
because you had seen the corruption and
I think that's that that's fair and you
brought up the syphilis in Guatemala
Peru I think you brought up Peru but
they brought up a source for Guatemala
which yeah this is terrible Hillary
Clinton did apologize for that and it
seems unfathomable for Americans to to
understand some of these things exactly
and so once you see 10 or 15 times that
criminals and government mad scientist
to bad things you start projecting the
pattern and I only say this is true
I mean 20 years ago 15 years ago 10
years ago I kind of got where so much
stuff was fake I thought well this is
fake well that's fake no that's just
where they had it organized most people
in government aren't bad they're good on
average so I began to realize it was
like a psychosis where everything was a
conspiracy
everything was staged then I would see
the world I wanted to see through that
I'm just being honest about it before
and I really learned that because some
of my listeners they would then project
onto me stuff that I knew wasn't true
and they were so sure that I was Bill
Hicks or they were so sure that I was
covering up sandy hook once I said I
thought it happened yeah it's like once
you kind of get like but isn't that the
media and the government's fault
and then they lie so much they've been
caught lying so much that once they've
been caught you can't blame people
anymore but not alive to my kids all the
time
and then I told the truth about
something I said hey you got a new
bicycle out there in the yard or I got
you a new motorcycle or I you know I got
you a new skateboard that lied to him 50
times there was never a skateboard out
there and they would finally say no dad
I don't believe it
even though there was a brand-new
skateboard or bicycle out there so at a
certain point the psychosis is what is
real and I think somebody like Eddie
Bravo has just gone to the other extreme
where I'm like hey I'll hire a [ __ ]
we'll go find that the Earl you know the
words that the earth the earth that the
earth is round yeah and and a certain
any justice on us it's flat I'm not
gonna look into it well in a certain
point he's kind of like gone you know
because you just put up the bill next
thing and I gotta say it's a very
entertaining conspiracy you do look
strikingly like bill looks like you've
someone were to say that you were
related I would say ok I believe it for
example if you were like a brother or an
uncle but here's the thing of course I
don't believe in that conspiracy let me
be really clear but the
korone of bill hicks i am the eggman but
the fact that you just addressed it you
know that people are gonna go nuts in
the comment section saying that's just
more proof that he's clearly Bill Hicks
right you know you've experienced this
now listen I'm in restaurants six or
seven times people go hey Bill hey Bill
man be telling gassing dan Rather what's
the frequency and when you finally turn
around if someone's yelling hey Bill
like oh I knew it
right yeah exactly you know what I did
are you ever concerned since naive
experiences that you've maybe done that
in the past with a conspiracy where
you've sort of seen confirmation bias
where someone's trusting no no this
isn't true and maybe you did that and
that's what it is this confirmation bias
because you've seen operation Northwoods
and Gladio and gulf of tonkin and blah
blah blah and then you see a Smollett I
have more people walk on the street and
go look at Jesse Smollett that was
staged you shouldn't have backed off on
Sandy Hook well I never even quote I was
just questioning I wasn't the guy that
first brought up Sandy Hook I questioned
it I thought I said I thought it
happened that made them sue me is like
oh we got it now he says it's real he
must have lied earlier but but like
Jesse Smollett like he's weird a lot I
mean how many of these hate crimes are
fake so there's a real hate crime if I
questioned it am i saying hate crimes
don't happen no but it's like babies and
incubators against in the Iraq war they
knew was a lie they had a PR firm so if
there was more babies thrown out of
incubators I would say is this staged
then it may turn out it's real in a
future war and then I'm like okay I'm
sorry but I had to question see see how
it kind of I say it's a psychosis it's a
psychosis when our authority figures lie
to us over and over and over again then
we start not knowing what strip right
yeah I understand that and I would I
would ask this as when I was watching
your segment segment your show the whole
segment was particularly nerdy Bravo
came out so that's why I'm saying it was
a little bit different right it took a
bit of a different direction um for
example you brought up syphilis
Guatemala Peru you bring up you know um
you brought up a few different issues
that are obviously true that we would
they didn't know the governor of
Virginia wants to kill babies after born
well no that was a miscommunication
there and I think that you didn't
understand that Eddie Bravo was being
facetious no I know he was later but I
mean take him Joe did no I'm not
knocking Joe for that I think it's
normal to not believe we're killing
babies after more
yeah we've done changed my mind and
abortion and most people don't believe
it when I tell them what abortion
actually is and then most people who
watch to change my mind don't believe
that every single person disagreed with
me once we brought out the fetal chart
if they are pro-choice today they go we
have to support abortion every single
one with the exception of - ever all the
web super videos like 10 million views
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
gonna shut you down you're reasonable
you're showing them facts they cannot
stand us talking to them for example you
start getting the rabbit-hole Nazis and
like we talk about sort of clockwork
elves and yes all very interesting
issues but for me and this is why I
haven't really delved into a lot of
conspiracies and I have the luxury of
not doing that because I'm late-night
host this is more comedy but it's
because when I look at all these
conspiracies I go a whole and second we
don't need a conspiracy to prove that
socialism that communism that socialist
dictatorships have murdered hundreds of
millions of people we don't need a
conspiracy to show that the biggest
fright right now you know you look at
Venezuela and then you look at people
here in the United States government who
go well you know what they just didn't
do it right we supported Chavez before
but we can do better than Venezuela so
you will not decry it right exactly to
me I go well I want us I want to keep my
powder dry for those issues that I see
as super pivotal that are out in plain
sight do you ever do you ever have any
regrets that maybe people kind of lumped
you off of the cut you roped you off is
nothing but a conspiracy guy when I know
that you've also talked about these
other sort of macro issues well that's
exactly what's going on is it's easy
when you're in the air for hours a day
because I've learned I used to do sad
Tigers it's fun and I used to like do
devil's advocate I don't do it now
because they take it out of context
right then they edit it together like my
shows been video for 15 years but notice
most of stuff you'll see on national
television it's audio right because
they're editing it's obvious when it's
jump cuts on video so I'm not even
defending myself I've said some things
that are wrong you know I've gone
overboard sometimes I've certainly
learned a lot as I've gotten older and
especially since I've been kind of put
through the paces of the whole
conspiracy world and people not
believing anything but but absolutely
most of what I cover what I do is right
out of the news just like you do I go
you know Rand Paul says Afghan war ended
pay for all soldiers of victory bonus
most of what I do is just objectively
there's an info wars.com story dozens
arrested for erecting anti-migrant
christian cross in greece government
announces its hurtful to muslims arrest
everyone you know that's dangerous that
that's a real story linked to the
government making its own announcement
saying don't you Christians try doing
that so 95 percent of what I do is
already cut and dry real information and
I can't even get people to admit what's
going on like like like you just said
socialism within 10 years wrecks every
country creates collapse total
nightmares communism even worse do we
have to test it again and so a lot of
this is prima facie it's on its face and
it's like how do we deal with this so
what happened with me is that you asked
Hillary looked at one of her biggest
opponents one of the biggest supporters
of Trump
they said this guy's got a very colorful
past a lot of stuff we can take out of
context you know for my own
entertainment I go crazy on the air at
least once a day let's let's go get this
colorful person let's edit it out of
context and make it Trump then Trump one
show then they believe their own
propaganda that shows like homeland and
shows on Comedy Central about me and
built me into Godzilla coming out of the
ocean against Tokyo and so now two and a
half years later they keep blasting me
with tanks and missiles and everything
trying to make me go away and it's like
they just keep building and building and
building but truth is we're bigger and
more successful than ever been Steven
and the thing is they won't stop they've
got the tanks and the laser beams
hitting me I'm like well I'm not
Godzilla well I ask you that because you
see we're bigger more successful than
ever but I did hear you say in Joe Rogan
show that once they figure out iTunes
that that really devastated you so well
I mean I did feel like tunes yeah but
but like exactly one door closes and
other notes I mean absolutely I mean
it's kind of like it's kind of putting
toothpaste back in the tube yes they did
a lot of things that for a month hit
it's really hard but then it totally
grew over here it's kind of like putting
a genie back in the bottle yeah because
you can't really put toothpaste back in
the tube it's probably up the best
analogy and I'm not up here trying to
say oh I'm great oh I'm so successful
I'm simply saying they don't even get
what they're doing right because it's
like
Twitter said Alex Jones is banned for
life I mean if I was a child kidnapper
they wouldn't say for life most the time
so so but now they're like Oh a road to
redemption they want to terrify people
that if you don't do what we say and if
you talk bad about the radical Muslims
you're a banned for life and you put it
on how Alex Jones on I mean I love Joe
to death he had the courage to have me
on they were like nervous when I was
going on in the countdown that they'd be
banned because they had me on and I just
said Joe Hollywood and big Texas sinking
ship why do you even care - goes no
you're right I don't care he goes I
wasn't selling out to these folks I just
get busy with life and don't want
conflict but you're right it's caused
more conflict not having you on and not
going after these people I'm gonna do it
I feel and I talked to Joe the other day
cuz I feel so good he goes I'm gonna
tear the hell out of Twitter he was he
was watched but just don't announce it
yet and he feels good now and he's on
cloud nine he's being himself but Joe I
knew and what I said to Tim all he said
I'm very liberal the only issue I
disagree with liberals on is the Second
Amendment so because Tim Poole sort of
sarcastically said you're basically a
socialist Joe I mean you're just more
liberal and Joe said yeah I'm very
liberal except on the second amendment
in my interactions with him that hasn't
been the case certainly the first
amendment I wouldn't consider him
liberal unless he's maybe sort of
loosely defined in class I would call
Joe a libertarian and I think he's
trying to live out in LA he's trying to
get along with him but I mean Joe likes
guns he likes bows so he's like wait I'm
a good guy why can't I like a cop can
have a gun but I can't I'm not a
criminal why can't I have a gun I mean I
would call Joe a libertarian and a
really smart guy but he's a father you
know he's he's pushing 60 and you know
he wants to just get along and I get
that yeah but he now gets good you can't
just get along your audience isn't just
gonna let you sit there and play
pattycake with Jack Dorsey it's not
happening so now he sees the great
feedback he's gotten he's not like a
leaf in the wind but he now gets but
people didn't hate him they just wanted
to grow a pair like you've done like I'm
not kissing your ass to him it's true
you're one of the few people other than
like a mark Dice who did not completely
throw me under the bus when I got banned
most other conservatives like pissed on
my grave said oh yeah he's bad oh don't
banish
bring this up because I will say
something and I don't want this to get
heated here but um I know that you why
didn't you have me on average first off
our booking contact doesn't work with
you anymore
but do you ever maybe regret sort of
going to war with a lot of conservatives
so there was one point right well I will
say I was like I don't have Alex on
right now because you said something
about me working for Ben Shapiro on your
show which is not true and I assume now
you were shooting from the hip but you
know that's the kind of thing that can
can kind of rub people the wrong way
where sometimes the second oh I agree
and here's the problem I don't have
psychosis all the time but you're on air
all the time you're irritated and later
I hear stuff like oh why did I say that
that's not true right and it's almost
like dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde I was like
being honest on gel about it sure as
I've gotten older I've gotten so
confident I used to I was worried about
stuff and now I don't have a governor
and I'm trying to get a governor Stephen
because now I don't know you're on as
old as I am but wait you're like 45 or
I've been through even I mean it here's
the problem the stress never got me down
it made me go crazy all the attacks all
the lies I became telling a crazy
crocodile it starts snapping at people I
love your show I'm always love your show
but if I said something mean I don't
remember saying that I apologize it
wasn't me that's why I do want to make
sure that clarify yeah we certainly
didn't piss on Your Grave when we talked
about it quite a bit me I said on air so
listen if you think Jones is off and
he's crazy conspiracy there's it can
happen to anyone it very likely at some
point will happen to us on a platform
but yeah on a personal level I go hon
why would you say that I work with Ben
Shapiro and that's why I'm not having
him on and yeah sometimes those things
I've said that I apologize if I don't
remember saying that believe me I don't
over half what I say trying to line any
level I guess you're on the air or maybe
you're not on the air Superior has his
own thing right Shapiro's his own thing
you have with daily daily wire a Ben
Shapiro I just don't I just don't get
like every headline like the genius the
man the myth and I like a pipe like whoa
and then and then and - you're right you
don't work with him I'm not even against
him I just don't get Michael Savage with
top ratings is taken off the air and
then all his radio stations are giving
up in Shapiro I have no idea it was on
terrestrial radio honestly but Ben's
been a longtime friend of mine he
actually just I met him through Andrew
Breitbart
when I was writing
it used to be big Hollywood before it's
called Breitbart anything and actually
Adam negotiate some contracts for me
just an hourly basis because I said hey
you're Jewish and conservative and we've
been friends but I've tried to avoid I
will say this as sort of a philosophy
and a big part is was Andrew Breitbart
actually a conservative once attacked me
on YouTube about a video that I did in
Detroit early on and Andrew called that
person up I don't want to honor this
person with air temp so I don't wanna
get into specifics of who it is but
someone can searches pretty quickly I
did a video on Detroit where I talked
about bear sightings in Detroit so I
talked about the unemployment how it's
been run by far leftist since 1961
really talked about how it's sort of
this iconic model leftist city and in
there there was a throwaway joke where I
said it's gotten so bad that not only
other packs of wild dogs which there are
in Detroit but there have been bear
sightings now the bear sightings have
I'm gonna get to the point here the bear
sightings have only actually occurred
outside of city limits but very close to
Detroit so this person just rakes me
over the coals and attacks me as a liar
you know kind of under this conspiracy
route that I don't know who I was
working for and Andrew called her called
her him up Z I almost slipped and said
listen you don't attack other
conservatives certainly not if we're
running on the same platform at did we
lose Alex yes people watching right now
terrestrial yep we didn't have to cut we
just lost Skype so Alex can confirm this
is not some conspiracy we just lost a
connection here long story short Andrew
Breitbart called this person said listen
a rule of mine is you do not attack
other conservatives particularly if you
haven't spoken with them in private and
tried to work it out first and this
person refused to retract it and this
person was no longer welcome
contributing to any of Andrews sites so
that's kind of been a defining again
since I was just a comedian and actor
and then kind of sat under the tutelage
of Andrew was I came up in this movement
more you know I think at 19 you're 20
years old
that's been a guiding rule for me that's
what I was that's what was kind of
getting back to you do you think that if
you could do it all over that would be
something that maybe you would give
greater absolutely you know I've gotten
where I have attacked some people I used
to actually follow that rule myself
because I'm not a big n fighter and then
when people don't stand up for you and
you're under attack you started tagging
everybody let them see what it feels
like is misery loves company
right but I've kind of I've been trying
to get back to my roots of not doing
that and you know the truth is I find
Vince appearing
we handsome I've got a painting of him
on my wall at my home and I want to
marry but like a.m. Coulter used to
really despise and then he both kind of
found yourself going back in the same
camp with Trump did did you two ever
meet was that ever awkward because you
two had some really did run into her at
the RNC and I did run into her at a few
other events and I've had her on a few
times you know and listen I get where
she was coming from now and I've moved
here's the thing I used to almost be
kind of liberal then I moved more
towards libertarian and I this happens
to most people as I get older I think
more kind of conservative so he's gotta
be a libertarian liberal than kind of a
libertarian and then now a little bit
more conservative in my views so yeah
and and used to I read an Coulter saying
something she wouldn't put satire at the
end so she go the Japanese on a really
be thankful for Fukushima that radiation
is really good for you and I'm like you
idiot it's killing him it was a joke a
sick joke but I was taking it as literal
now I get that a lot of what she does
it's a teracle so I like a liking
culture I'm really envious of ben
shapiro and obsessed with him no no
seriously the point is I don't want to
fight with anybody you're absolutely
right i think you and i and ben shapiro
we should all brought up his name was
because you said that I worked for him
and I'm just like I was just like no
that was somewhat irritating because I
had to I had to feel like you with Bill
Hicks a bunch of comments going no I
don't know where this is coming from let
me ask you this though we do have to get
going if you want people to know Alex
Jones for if you want people right now
watching they should know Alex Jones as
what what do you want to be known for
what do you want your legacy to most be
you've been a controversial figure like
you said you kind of transition from
more liberal libertarian to where you
are now how would you want to be
remembered or known as somebody that
wants to live in a free country in a
free world who believes in humanity and
who loves private property and God the
Second Amendment and and who's a fan of
Americana and who wants to see that
continue and wants to defeat people like
aoc and little vampire bat Kim's young
on the rest of it and who just again
isn't going to back down the cultural
Marxists all these bullies them that's
that's who I am it's what I stand for
and I
believe in America I bet on America and
I think America is coming back I think
it's up to people like you and I and all
your viewers and listeners who are the
brain trust of this country the people
watching you right now are no doubt the
most focused most involved Americans on
the planet yeah because there's
Americans all over the world and we
really are special we are something
special there is something that is truly
independent and exceptional about
America it's that idea it's that spirit
that's why people want to come here and
so it's that spirit of America that I'm
searching for and I think I found it and
I'm just glad to be here with you and
anybody wants to find out what I'm
actually saying versus what mainstream
media is obsessed with and visit
infowars.com
or news Wars common Steven anytime
you're not busy what you know you're a
hard worker please come on my show yeah
well I appreciate that and like I said
we were wanted to be in South at South
by Southwest year this year but I've
been banned along with every working
member of my staff as far as I know so
we'll have to find some other people and
it's it's been a weird spell at South by
Southwest but all right well thank you
Infowars I come Alex thank you for
taking the time and I appreciate it and
heal up with with your bicep there
brother don't go crazy don't take it off
the cast but don't go crazy doing
preacher curls at the gym or anything
don't worry I won't hair Crowder